hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a Uruguayan drama film called
a 12-year night spoilers ahead watch out
and take care
[Music]
at the beginning of the film a bunch of
men are dragged into prison after
getting them blindfolded and binding
their hands the military police beat
them mercilessly they have been arrested
without a court hearing or a verdict and
have no clue if they will be imprisoned
for some days months or even years a few
days later the police decide to separate
them into different cells and torture
them in solidarity three of the
prisoners Pepe Mauricio and Fernandez
are transferred to an establishment a
few miles away the police see them as
play things and treat them as such the
poor men are covered in gasoline and
threatened to be burnt to death with
Terror in their hearts they accept their
fate but fortunately enough it turns out
the policemen were playing a sick joke
on them the movie is set in 1973 Uruguay
when it was ruled by a Civic military
dictatorship times were harsh for the
Uruguayan population especially for the
non-supporters of the dictator among all
the parties revolting against the
dictatorship is the leftist tupamaros
group which is in embroiled in guerrilla
warfare with the National Police the
three men imprisoned are Pepe Mauricio
and Fernandez the members of the
tupamaros group who have been caught by
the National Police and illegally held
as hostages in a government-run prison
this is the second prison they have been
transferred to but they won't be here
long because the department has decided
to rotate them around the prisons all
throughout the country so that they
won't be able to escape the men now
getting out of prison will be difficult
but they are aware that they have fallen
into the Pit of Doom in the morning they
try to look out the window in their
cells the prison guards realize that men
do not deserve the right to look at the
sunlight for going against their
government in the next hour the windows
are covered the scene changes to 12
months later as the guards wanted Pepe
Mauricio and Fernandez haven't seen the
sunlight in a year they have been given
just enough food to live and no
additional facilities they haven't even
talked to anyone during this time
because they were beaten brutally if
they did it is finally time for them to
be transferred again and the three hope
for a slightly better life as they had
hoped they are put into jail with a bed
it feels like the greatest luxury to the
guys who are used to the comfort of the
concrete floor one day the commander
comes to Fernandez and tells him that he
is getting a chance to meet his family
who has threatened a lawsuit if they
don't get to see him however he has to
be quiet about how he is being treated
in the peasantry he has given his first
bath in months a fresh haircut and new
clothes for the occasion finally the day
comes when Mauricio gets to meet his
parents and daughter overwhelmed by the
reunion their eyes are filled with tears
however the next thing they know
Fernandez being dragged away because the
meeting time is already over he tries to
resist and is beaten in front of his
family they cry at how their son is
being treated but can do nothing about
it less than a year later they are
transferred to their fourth prison
Mauricio and Fernandez are kept in
underground cells with a window on the
ceiling sometimes the soldiers give them
food and water but they're starved most
days after being thirsty for months the
prisoners see a stream of water falling
through the window but it turns out to
be a guard peeing it's probably still
good as time time passes the guys start
communicating with each other through
noises they count the number of times
one knocks on the wall and relate it to
the alphabet it gives them an activity
to do in solitary confinements and helps
their loneliness just as long as they
don't say they want pizza however it is
different for Pepe who is alone hell
that the bottom of a grain silo his only
friends are the ants and insects don't
give up hope buddy Paul Rudd's in there
somewhere after more than a year of
communicating with Knox Mauricio and
Fernandez are able to play chess in the
same way a close-up of their fingers
shows that they are scraped and wounded
because of the continuous knocking on
the other hand Pepe's mental condition
worsens as he starts hallucinating about
the torture he received he frequently
sees his mother through the window and
thinks the hallucinations are real at
the same time his mother is outside
trying to get permission to meet her son
she stands in the rain for hours before
being told he isn't available for family
meetups since he is a national terrorist
touche I guess Pepe frequently hears Two
Soldiers talk about a girl one of them
is interested in he knows there's story
entirely and knows just what the
soldiers should do to impress the girl
one day he talks after months and tells
the soldier to write the girl a love
letter he even offers to write the
letter for him if given a pen and piece
of paper the soldier insults him and
calls him an imbecile but after a few
days he gives in and asks Pepe for
advice with his help the man writes the
girl he likes a beautiful letter and
manages to impress her the news goes
around to the prison and reaches
Sergeant Al Zamora he also has a girl he
wants to get close to and needs Pepe's
help to impress her he listens to some
details about the said girl and ends up
writing another beautiful letter
impressed Sergeant alzamora gives him a
pen and a notebook as a reward this Pepe
gets girls just like that cartoon skunk
except he isn't cancelable from that day
onwards his life gets a bit better with
the Sergeant's help he has given decent
food and allowed to listen to the news
on the radio however it ends soon when
the guards are ordered to move him to
another prison on his way to be
transferred Pepe gets a chance to look
at the sky and a field for the first
time in years just when he thinks he
might be able to live longer he is
thrown into solitary confinement yet
again this time his hallucinations get
worse and he imagines himself getting
electrocuted it happens several times
every day and weakens his will to live
at this point Pepe wishes for death
rather than Freedom somewhere else
Mauricio and Fernandez continue living
the way that they do since they can talk
to each other they do not feel as lonely
as Pepe does suddenly one day the guards
bring in tables books a typewriter and
several other things for them the
prisoners are worried rather than
excited because they would never be
granted such privileges in normal
conditions their doubt turns out to be
true when they find out a team from the
Red Cross Society has come to their
prison to check how they treat their
Prisoners the tables and books are just
a show for the officers so the prison
doesn't get into trouble for ill
management Mauricio is brought in front
of the officers for interrogation he
imagines telling them that he doesn't
even get a proper toilet but in reality
he has just asked his name the guards
taken back and the tables and books are
take taken away as soon as possible
while cleaning the room the guards find
a bar of soap that wasn't there before
it turns out that Mauricio had been
using it to communicate with someone the
military Chief is called to deal with
the situation he interrogates Mauricio
asking him what the carvings mean and
finding out that he has been drawing
chess moves although mad the chief
Praises Mauricio's sharp brain and the
matter is dismissed but before leaving
Mauricio recalls the day he was arrested
he remembers how his wife was killed and
his house had several holes because of
the gunshots the chief Smiles because he
was the leader of the brawl that
happened then and Mauricio's wife was
killed because of his order Mauricio
could definitely beat his ass in chess
though in the meantime Pepe's mother
hasn't given up on wanting to meet her
son someday even though it has been
several years she visits every prison he
goes to hoping that the rules will bend
someday this time she brings Pepe a pink
pot for defecation and water she wants
the items to be delivered to him even
though she cannot meet him herself to
her Delight she is allowed to talk to
her son for five minutes the
the meeting is overwhelming but they
keep their calm Pepe tells her about his
mental health and how he thinks
something has been planted in his brain
that talks to him every day he talks
about giving up which enrages the woman
she yells at him to be strong and win
against his enemies the Meetup ends but
her words keep Pepe motivated for the
next few days he asks the guards every
day if he can get the gifts from his
mother but they refuse to provide him
with anything come on guys Let me poop
in that pink pot now one day he hears an
event taking place outside and uses it
as an opportunity to get his belongings
he yells at the window exposing a guard
for cheating on his wife and getting
syphilis the guard stops him surprised
that the man knows so much about his
private life when Pepe threatens to
shout even louder he is given the pink
pot and a glass of water alongside it
when the commander gets a hint of Pepe's
degrading mental health he allows some
mercy and makes him go to a psychiatrist
the doctor is a kind woman who explains
to Pepe what he is going through Pepe
you're definitely losing your mind she
asks him to write because it is the only
way he can control his thoughts when she
she finds out the guards don't allow in
pen and paper she sends the commander a
special request to allow him everything
he needs for medical needs finally comes
1980 Mauricio and Fernandez listen to
the news on the radio playing somewhere
outside they hear that the nation is
voting for or against democracy and the
results have come in 39 say no and 61
say yes Mauricio and Fernandez ask each
other which side they are on because
they did not get to hear half of the
news suddenly the guards barge into
their cells and beat them black and blue
to have lost against the revolutionists
it is clear that the winning 61 percent
was pro-democracy this is the first
beating in their life that Mauricio and
Fernandez take happily soon the nation
will celebrate democracy and the purpose
of their imprisonment will be fulfilled
two years later in 1982 the prisoners
are transferred yet again unbeknownst to
Mauricio and Fernandez Pepe also is
transferred to the same prison in the
new Penitentiary everything is different
and they are finally treated as humans
at first they are given proper medical
treatment Pepe is then approached by
Sergeant alzamora who is now a chief
guard he shows off his wedding ring
revealing that he married the girl Pepe
helped him impress both of them laugh at
each other acknowledging the absurdity
of the situation thanks for making my
life even better than it already was now
get back in your cell you dirty Shmo the
sergeant asks Pepe if there's something
he can do to pay his debt in the
following scene Mauricio Fernandez and
pepe are reunited outside they have been
close to each other in the past decade
but they never got to see each other's
faces enjoying the sun and the fresh air
they sit down outside for an hour it is
almost as if the short period of time
healed them of everything they've been
through since their imprisonment next we
see the prisoners looking into the
mirror the last time they saw themselves
they were youthful and happy they are
sad to see what time and improper
treatment have done to them but still
they take the freedom to go to the
toilet eat food daily and live like a
human as a gift when they get the chance
the three talk to each other through
their cells and ask each other about
some fellow Revolution missionaries some
of their friends died and some are said
to be living like them going from prison
to prison Pepe plants a seed in the pot
that his mother gifted him the poop will
fertilize it well days pass and the seed
grows into a plant I knew it the three
now wear clean clothes interact with
other inmates cook and live a decent
life then in 1985 Pepe is called into
the Commander's office and asked to sign
some papers the commander threatens to
kill Pepe outside and reveals that they
are actually release papers with the
establishment of democracy the
revolutionists who fought for it are
being freed Fernandez and Mauricio are
also released alongside all other
prisoners but as the others leave
Mauricio stays in the kitchen cleaning
the dishes for a long time after 12
years in prison he is almost scared of
what life has for him outside in the
following scene the prisoners get into a
bus and are taken to the city a crowd of
people waits for them outside cheering
on the heroes who fought for democracy
the men look at the sky the water and
the greenery having missed the little
things in life for for so long upon
finally reaching their Hometown they are
reunited with their families Pepe shows
his mother the beautiful flower that is
grown out of the seed he planted in her
poop pot the movie ends as the prisoners
hug and cry with their families
recognizing that the hard times have
passed in an epilogue we find out that
Pepe later became the president of
Uruguay and his friends also had a good
life
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching